هذه الصواريخ الدقيقه تنطلق لاصابه
اهدافها بعمق عشره كيلو مترات في البحر
الاسود
راجمات من الولايات المتحده وايطاليا
وهيمارز من رومانيا تطلق صواريخها من
اراضي الاخيره على مسافه 100 كم من الحدود
مع اوكرانيا
هذا جانب من مناورات ديفندر 23 التي
تنفذها الولايات المتحده مع حلفائها في
النيتو فوق القاره الاوروبيه
هناك دلاله مهمه لخوضنا التدريبات كفريق
واحد وليس كدول منفصله هناك قوه مهام
موحده ومركز تكتيكي موحد عبر استخدام
بروتوكولات موحده واخيرا المكان الذي تجري
فيه التدريبات له دلاله مهمه فنحن في
الجناح الشرقي للنيتو المناورات بالذخيره
الحيه تهدف ايضا كما يقول المشاركون الى
ابراز قدره النيتو على تحريك اسلحه فتاكه
لحمايه اراضيه
[موسيقى]
23 تحمل دينارا هنا في رومانيا احتاج دول
الجناح الشرقي لحلف شمال الاطلسي وعلى
الحدود مع اوكرانيا التي تحتدم فيها الحرب
فالولايات المتحده تقول ان هذه المناورات
التي يشارك فيها سبعه الاف من جنودها تظهر
قدرتها على نقل قواتها بسرعه لحمايه
الجناح الشرقي لحلف النيتو
هنا في شرق رومانيا تشارك مدرعات
الامريكيه في عبور جسر مائي مدعومه بانزال
على ضفه نهر الدانوب تقوم به القوات
الرومانيه
وتشارك في مناورات دفندر 20 دوله تسعى الى
البرهنه على تكامل قوات النيتو التي
تستخدم في تدريباتها اسلحه زودت بها
اوكرانيا لمساعدتها في شن هجومها المضاد
على القوات الروسيه
فدي منصور الجزيره بمنطقه البحر الاسود في
رومانيا